senator bernie sanders is catching the
attention of the president and even some
possible challengers in 2020 by
introducing his longtime passion a
medicare-for-all proposal this week the
sweeping reform plan that calls for
single-payer universal health care was a
frequent talking point for Sam burrs
Sanders on the campaign trail
it was summarized by President Trump as
quote a curse on the US and its people
here to talk about it is Anna Palmer
senior Washington correspondent for
Politico Anna good morning good morning
what are some of the highlights of this
legislation it sounds pretty good right
it means you would not pay your any
premiums or deductibles your Medicare
would expand to dental vision in four
years all of this would be covered so as
far as kind of you and me looking at it
it sounds pretty good how do you pay for
it though the big question right and
that is something that Sanders has
really struggled to actually talk about
he'd this week he put out a proposal
saying we're gonna increase payroll tax
we're gonna increase taxes on the
wealthy but I think there's a lot of
skepticism that they can actually find
the way to pay for all of this
there are 16 Democratic senators who've
lined up in support of this is that
about what you'd expected well look at
this in 2013 not a single other Democrat
supported this bill so this has been a
big shift for them clearly has to do
with his success on the campaign trail
in 2016 and trying to figure out how
they can get those primary voters yeah
is some of this also maybe shift to 2020
and who we may see in the race oh yes we
are already in the capital there's
already a 20/20 watch happening every
day and it is certainly in terms of what
I think Sanders wants is a litmus test
he wants to get all of these potential
Senators Kamala Harris Kirsten
Gillibrand and others who might run on
the record here right so but I mean at
the same time there's very slim chance
this legislations going anywhere
so what's the purpose I mean X women's
general generous
no I think this is definitely a
standards getting people on the record
so that when Democrats were to take
power in Congress and in the White House
this would be something that would move
her he could move forward when we see
this though in other countries and it
works people start to wonder as you said
the very beginning this looks great it
looks great we all have health care why
is it so difficult to achieve here in
the you
I think this is the frustration that a
lot of people have in Washington it's
hard to get anything done I think as
Donald Trump said health cares a lot
harder than he thought it was gonna be
there's big business involved you have
the health insurance companies
pharmacies everybody that might not want
their piece of the pie to be less and so
I think there's a lot of complications
when it comes to health care and they've
really had a hard time trying to figure
out how to move forward what do you what
would have to happen do you think for
health care to become you know a
significant issue that you could find
agreement on I think what's gonna be
interesting is this next to be great
you're having this kid this bill that's
gonna move forward on Obamacare repeal
so there's definitely a lot of talk
about it with Republicans and Democrats
trying to figure out a way forward but I
think you'd have to have a real shift in
terms of everybody kind of getting on
the same page about how they think they
should move forward with it so where do
we go with health care then that's the
big question right and I think right now
you're having Republicans really
struggling with that in Congress because
they promised you know repeal replace
for six seven years and they've really
failed to do that so far there's no
indication right now that there's going
to be successful in the short term on
this all right Anna Palmer thank you
thank you